Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je demande, s’il vous plaît,
votre attention.
Serrez votre ceinture de sécurité.
On est en train de décoller.
Merci.
(Voix en anglais) Départ. H-5. Quatre,
(En anglais) Trois, deux, un...
(Voix en anglais) Allumage du booster.
Décollage.
Depuis mon enfance, je rêve
de dessiner des navettes spatiales.
C'était ma passion.
Et ça,
ça m’a vraiment suivi partout,
toute ma vie.
Je suis né dans ce village,
au centre de l’Italie,
et c’est là que j’ai les mémoires
les plus chères de ma vie.
À l’intérieur de ce village,
il y a un parc.
On peut dire que c’est une fusion
de culture, d’art, d’architecture,
de paysagisme, de nature.
Et ça, ça m'a forgé aussi.
C’est là que je jouais avec mes amis.
En même temps, je suis né
au début de l’époque spatiale,
quand on a fait
les premiers pas sur la Lune.
Ici, la gravité est un petit peu plus
forte que sur la Lune, mais ça va.
C’est ça que je fais aujourd’hui :
je suis architecte spatial.
Quand on dessine
une structure pour la Lune,
on a affaire avec un environnement
qui est très extrême.
Il n’y a pas d’atmosphère,
il n’y a pas d’eau.
Quand on regarde avec nostalgie
à l’horizon la Terre,
on voit la beauté.
La Terre, finalement,
c’est notre navette spatiale
qui nous porte tous dans l’univers.
Elle nous donne aussi toutes les
ressources dont on a besoin pour vivre.
Mais c’est à nous maintenant
de partager ses ressources
pour qu'on puisse vivre bien.
Maintenant, on va atterrir et on va voir
ici comment partager ces ressources.
Vous voyez la beauté ?
C'est un paradis.
L’homme vit en paix,
en harmonie avec la nature.
C'est magique.
Mais en même temps,
j’ai découvert qu’il y a aussi des aspects
soi-disant négatifs dans cette beauté.
Il y a des enfants et des femmes
qui cherchent l’eau,
partagent des sources d’eau
avec les animaux,
remplissent des tâches d’eau très lourdes.
Et cela, tous les jours.
Presque 60% de la population de
l’Éthiopie souffrent de ces problèmes-là.
Et selon les statistiques,
toutes les 90 secondes,
il y a un enfant
qui habite cette navette spatiale
qui nous laisse
à cause de la qualité de l’eau.
Donc la situation est
quand même intenable.
En tant qu’architecte spatial,
je me suis dit : « Comment
je peux aider dans cette situation ? »
J’ai commencé à faire des croquis,
à chercher l’inspiration -
parce qu’architecte,
je cherche toujours l’inspiration.
La principale, c’est l’arbre de Warka -
en Éthiopie, c’est une institution.
Un village qui n’a pas d’arbre de Warka
n’est pas respecté.
L’arbre est très intelligent
parce qu’il utilise la communauté
pour survivre à la déforestation.
Comment il fait ça ?
Il donne toutes les ressources :
l’oxygène, la nourriture -
il donne des figues.
C’est un arbre énorme.
Il fait de l’ombre.
À l’ombre, on fait [inaudible]
les réunions de la communauté.
Tout se passe sous l’arbre.
Il y a aussi les besoins spirituels
parce que c’est là qu’on prie.
On a une connexion avec les esprits.
Si on regarde la nature,
vous voyez combien d’exemples on a
de manières d’attraper
l’eau de l’atmosphère.
La nature nous montre tous les jours
des techniques très intelligentes.
Maintenant, c’est à nous de les étudier,
de les comprendre et de les copier.
Et on peut même faire mieux
aujourd’hui que la nature.
Et c’est ça qu’on a fait
pendant des années.
Les civilisations anciennes ont trouvé des
solutions très innovatives et [durables].
Nous, on a oublié ça
et aujourd’hui, on ne sait plus faire
comme on faisait à l’époque.
Ce que vous voyez ici,
ce panorama,
en fait, c’est chez moi.
Je suis entouré par des champs d’oliviers.
L’olivier, pour nous,
c’est comme le Warka.
Pour ramasser les olives,
on utilise un filet.
Ces filets-là,
à la fin de la journée, on les plie,
on les met sur les branches.
Parce que dans ces saisons-là, en
novembre, il y a beaucoup de brouillard.
Et le matin quand on arrive sur le champ,
pour retrouver où on avait terminé,
on regarde et on trouve.
Et quand on prend le filet,
il est mouillé, il y a plein d’eau.
Quand j’étais en Éthiopie,
il y avait beaucoup d’humidité.
Je me suis dit : « Pourquoi on ne peut
pas utiliser la même approche,
les mêmes filets ? »
C’est comme ça que le concept,
petit à petit, il commence à se former.
Avec une structure qui soit simple,
qui soit construite sur place
avec les matériaux disponibles,
qui n’utilise pas d’énergie,
qui soit passive.
Des tout premiers croquis
au premier prototype,
pour tester physiquement comment
ces structures peuvent se comporter.
Vous voyez, ça,
c’est le prototype numéro un.
Il fait dix mètres de hauteur.
Il est moins lourd que moi.
Ça fait 80 kilos.
C’est l’architecture spatiale
qui m’a enseigné ça -
des structures légères.
On l’a testé au mois de novembre.
On a attendu le brouillard
qui vient de la vallée.
Et voilà le résultat.
le test est en cours.
On a attendu, on a attendu, on a attendu.
Et ça, c’est la [preuve]
qu’on était dans une bonne direction.
On a commencé à développer, à implémenter
cette idée avec différents prototypes.
J’ai voulu revenir en Éthiopie,
avec cette idée et la tester sur place.
Et là, on est à Dorzé.
C’est un village qui est
à 2 400 mètres sur un plateau.
Dans le fond, il y a un lac,
le lac d’Abaya,
qui produit beaucoup d’humidité
et de nuages.
Ça, c’est la communauté
avec laquelle on a travaillé.
Ce sont des gens très spéciaux.
Quand j’ai vu les constructions,
les maisons qu’ils construisent -
regardez, elles sont incroyables.
Tout ça est fait avec
un seul matériau : le bambou.
En collaborant avec eux,
j’ai beaucoup appris, énormément.
C’était un échange vraiment intéressant.
Après quelques mois de travail,
beaucoup de défis, de difficultés,
on est arrivé à construire, petit à petit,
sur le site qu’on avait choisi
la nouvelle tour, la version trois.
La communauté était très contente,
mais surtout orgueilleuse,
parce que ce sont eux-mêmes
qu’ils l’ont construite.
C’était une collaboration.
Ils se sont vraiment identifiés
dans la structure.
Quelle nouvelle, pour une culture
de tradition, d’intégrer l’innovation.
Ils étaient fiers, ils étaient contents.
Mais moi, je voulais
encore d’autres défis.
Je me suis dit : « Et si on allait
dans un autre contexte ? »
Maintenant, on arrive au Cameroun.
Un contexte très différent de l'Éthiopie.
Toujours en Afrique.
On est au sud du Cameroun.
Ici, j’ai découvert
la forêt du bassin du Congo,
c’est un des poumons
de notre navette spatiale Terre.
C'est grâce à elle qu'on respire.
Ici, les Pygmées Bagyeli sont les rois.
Plutôt, c’étaient les rois de la forêt.
Maintenant, ils sont chassés.
Ils vivent dans
ces conditions déplorables.
La forêt a été privatisée.
On coupe des arbres,
on coupe des arbres tous les jours.
On a chassé les Pygmées
qui vivent maintenant au bord de la route
dans cette situation-là.
Comment peut-on les aider ?
J’ai demandé au chef de village :
« Qu’est-ce qu’on peut faire
pour vous aider un peu ? »
Il a dit : « On a besoin surtout d’un
abri où il ne pleuve pas à l’intérieur,
où on puisse ne pas dormir par terre. »
On a créé ce qu’on appelle
la Warka House 1.
Tout simplement un toit,
un plancher soulevé du sol.
Et ça, ça a déjà permis à cette petite
communauté d'avoir une vie plus digne,
plus saine, améliorée,
plus confortable, de vivre mieux.
Et là, j’ai trouvé la motivation
et le courage de [inaudible].
On peut faire plus.
Et si on construisait plus de maisons ?
Et si on apportait l’eau et tous
les services qui sont absents ?
Là est née l’idée
de construire le village Warka,
toute l’infrastructure dont on peut
avoir besoin quand on n’a plus rien.
Parce que eux, vraiment,
ils n’ont plus rien.
On a commencé ce défi en
collaboration avec les Pygmées,
mais aussi d'autres communautés locales
qui habitent dans les environs.
Et tous ensemble, on a commencé
à construire dans la forêt,
à l’intérieur de la forêt même,
ces villages faits avec les mains.
Ici, l’acteur principal,
ce sont les mains.
Beaucoup de mains ensemble.
Il n’y a pas de machines,
il n’y a pas de produit industriel.
Tout est travaillé de cette façon simple,
avec des outils simples, sans électricité.
Tous les matériaux viennent
de la forêt qui est tout autour.
Il y a la terre, il y a l’argile,
il y a le bois, il y a le bambou,
il y a les feuilles de raphia,
(Voix d’homme) Je vais essayer.
les fibres naturelles,
les lianes, la paille.
Ce sont ça les éléments
qu’on utilise - et l’eau.
Avec ça, on est en train
de construire un village
fait avec des technologies
et des savoir-faire traditionnels
qui appartiennent aux
différentes régions du Cameroun.
Le Cameroun est très grand
et chaque région a ses traditions.
Ensemble, avec la technologie spatiale
que j’apporte en termes de design,
les projets avancent.
Et maintenant,
je vous annonce qu’on est presque
à une minute de l’atterrissage,
donc préparez-vous,
on est en train de rentrer.
Le village prend forme, jour après jour.
C'est un travail lent, mais on avance.
Il y a des maisons,
il y a des tours Warka pour l’eau.
Il y aura des toilettes, des lieux pour
cuisiner, des lieux pour se rencontrer,
des lieux pour l’artisanat,
pour l’économie,
issue de l’agriculture, issue du tourisme.
Il y a beaucoup de touristes
qui viennent pour voir les Pygmées.
Le voyage se termine avec une réflexion
que je voulais partager avec vous.
Aujourd’hui, notre société
est nommée la société de l’Ere spatiale.
Ceux qui ont été capables d’aller
dans l’espace, l’endroit où il n’y a rien,
n’est-ce pas ?
Et maintenant ne peut-on pas
utiliser ce savoir-faire
et cette envie de faire
pour travailler dans
la navette spatiale, la Terre,
pour améliorer la vie de tous les jours
avec ces technologies-là,
fusionnées avec les traditions
qu’on a développées
pendant des siècles, des millénaires.
Si on met ça ensemble,
je pense qu’on peut améliorer la vie des
passagers qui sont le plus dans le besoin.
Mais finalement, c’est
la même navette spatiale.
On y est tous, n’est-ce pas ?
Donc ça va être au bénéfice
de nous tous, ensemble.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)